coming soon to neverwinter more call to
arms skirmishes orcas alt battle for the
bridge and temple defense these events
allow players to participate regardless
of level and the experience is tailored
for each individual member of the party
players who may have previously missed
out on these skirmishes can now jump in
at any time play through the epic
missions and win amazing rewards in orc
assault players are tasked with
protecting the neverwinter guard post in
the tower district from waves of hostile
orcs mog the crusher will join the fray
so work together to bring him down in
battle for the bridge players fight for
control of a massive stone bridge over
the fires of Mount Haute no fight
through the flames and confront grunt
rocks the relentless and his fire giants
in Temple defense players must defend
the temple of kalimdor and AB and downs
against hordes of the undead defeat the
powerful mini bosses and destroy the
crystals to save the temple upon
completing these events players will be
rewarded with unique weapon skins and
fashion items equip them and show your
valor these call to arms skirmishes are
fast action packed weekend events join
the battles while they last